spintires is currently on the steam top
sellers list and it's got me excited
why because marketing people wouldn't
know what to do with this thing
imagine this being unveiled at an e3
press conference or something do that
[ __ ]
or an exclusive announcement on a major
gaming outlet
but there it is PC gamers especially
ones heavily invested in digital-only
products they don't care about what
games are trending they don't care about
what celebrities are playing they want
to know where they can have unique
experiences contained in digital worlds
or maybe not but whatever because with
the duo which is kind of precisely why
this is great for me personally there is
a much begin to enjoy within spintires
but there is this deformable terrain mud
physics system which is something very
transfixing to have being simulated at
this level of detail while there is a
draw to want to successfully navigate
the gooey terrain and deliver the lumber
I couldn't help but wonder how this mud
Sim will change the face of gaming
driving services just haven't been
simulated like this in a game before it
reminds me of trials it started out with
this amazing 2d physics engine in a
flash game but I distinctly remember
trials - second edition blowing up a bit
bringing lean acceleration and break
physics into the spotlight as this PC
only game on Steam that had really good
word mouth buzz it wasn't like a
powerhouse game by any means but it
brought this idea that simulating the
weight transfer of a bike can lead to
amazing gameplay experience and it
launched it into one of the best goddamn
gave you franchises in history is spin
tires mud system going to be in the next
dirt or ARMA with tank treads or Cod or
GTA it might and it might spur on other
developers to just try and do better
hard surface physics I guess I think
that's pretty awesome
but then again has water physics ever
been as good as wave race 64
you